aus seehofer findet einfach keine frau
zumindest nicht für das heimat
ministerium ein ganz klarer fall für
mich casting von rissen
[Musik]
was halten sie von politik politik ist
wichtig gut dass sich die männer darum
kümmern wie politik sagt mir nichts
der neue job beinhaltet natürlich eine
angemessene kleiderordnung stehen ihnen
die antl ja ja sehr gut
herr seehofer hat sie gerade kritisiert
und sie weinen wie sie heulen oder c sie
nehmen ist wie ein mann
ich nehme es also was sind ihre talente
durchsetzungsfähig auch mal mit der hand
auf den tisch und das gefällt ihm
wahrscheinlich weil die frau das ist
nicht gut da müssen wir jedes casting
abbrechen warum machen sie das ist eine
ernste heimatschutz es geht um heimat
schutz unserer heimat muss geschützt
werden von männern wie seehofer ja sehr
gut findet keine frau warum gibt es so
wenig gute frau
es gibt sehr viele gute frauen und warum
gerade horst seehofer keine findet das
müssen sie eben sparen
ich führe ein casting durch für das
heimat ministerium
möchten sie etwas fragen sind sie eine
moderne frau
ich denke schon ja gut da war es das
danke
[Musik]
man hat der kredite könnten sie sich
vorstellen für herrn seehofer im
heimatmuseum zu arbeiten
wenigstens teilzeit
eine frage noch da sie durch horst
seehofer wacht morgens neben ihnen auf
mit sicherheit nicht neben ja mit einer
frau gegen das schnell mal die emotionen
durch können sie einen kühlen kopf
bewahren wenn sie putin mit nacktem
oberkörper sie trotzdem weiß ich nicht
[Gelächter]
das hat sich auch spaß gemacht
seehofer jemand etwas oli ich habe doch
noch die richtige frau für seehofer
gefunden sie ist bayern
und damit zurück ins studio
[Applaus]